how did he get to be the buzz that we
know how do we get to make him into a
space ranger that we recognize
[Music]
the big thing for me was making the
movie fairly grounded in the sense that
i didn't want
everything to be so fantastical that
there was no connection to it as an
audience planet that they land on i
wanted it to seem familiar and inviting
at first and then be a little dangerous
so i think we really focused on trying
to make something that was
had elements of familiarity
but
were also slightly different since most
sci-fi movies are filmed on earth
there's always a feeling of being on
earth and there's part of the movie that
we wanted to feel like it was not super
fantastical in a way plenty of movies
where you know they have like
neon trees
and bright bushes and stuff like that
and that really wasn't the aesthetic
that i was interested in pursuing we did
have a brief moment where we talked
about should should the gravity be the
same we're doing an animated film and we
only have about 90 minutes and it would
just be yet another thing that the
audiences would have to acclimate to
what does it mean to be have a different
gravity and it just it just became
utterly confusing and so we decided okay
a zero gravity fight
gotta definitely have that that's gonna
be cool it's gonna be awesome but
gravity should basically feel the same
so that movement
and what what you would expect in terms
of expressiveness would be the same
because like for example if you don't
have gravity as we learned from talking
with one of our astronaut friends on the
iss you're in a perpetual smile because
there's nothing
pulling your face down okay so there's
all they're all of the cues that you
would normally expect just go away when
you don't have gravity
i think i wanted it to be a clash of
familiar shapes as far as somewhere
between a crustacean and an insect with
illuminated eyes and an asymmetry to it
or or multiple eyes to it so that you're
not
thinking about it as a character it's
important narratively to dehumanize
that kind of character when you're going
to have them be an adversary it's very
much a well-worn trick to do that i mean
in alien they have no eyes even
in the takashi mike movie 13 assassins
where you have 13 assassins fighting
hordes of samurai they all have hats
that cover their eyes you have such a
limited time to
get the audience on board with uh
you know if you're gonna have buzz
blasting these guys we can't think that
they're adorable if you add too much or
if you throw in you know it just it it's
just more than anybody can track in that
short period of time
i wanted
the movie to be an investigation on the
hero mythos dealing with
really two approaches to success
you know for these kind of movies i feel
like there's either the the superhero
that solves all the problems
or that the team of specialists that
achieves the mission in a heist movie to
pay off the notion of buzz you need to
have at some point in the movie he needs
to be feel like he's the superhero
character and ending with that felt not
great just felt like a little
progressive in a way that was not
helpful
and there was an opportunity to tell
something slightly different and to
investigate the nature of what heroism
is viewed through society and through
the way that media messages success
often by the superhero myth of rugged
individualism when the reality is uh
it actually takes a team of people to
achieve really anything and so much the
movie is a thinly available metaphor for
filmmaking the nature of time dilation
and time jumps is based around feeling
that the filmmakers have
after finishing a long project and
returning home new lease to my home in
portland oregon and feeling like
everything had changed or time had moved
on and you had been jumping through time
it was important to tell the nature of
a character who is caught between
worrying about the future and invested
in the nostalgia of the past and trying
to rectify or get back to a past that he
felt where he was successful instead of
finding a way to be successful in a
present that he didn't recognize
i wanted to
expand upon the the core idea of buzz
which is buzz as a disagreement over the
nature of reality we found really
quickly if you made the movie the buzz
lightyear that we saw in toy story he
has a very
two-dimensional
angle to it because he's a caricature of
science fiction
archetypes it's really hard to care
about that character after about 20
minutes
if you stay in that in that rigid um
very surface mode so buzz is a character
that's bound by duty and feels an
obligation to to
toe the company line as it were
but we needed to make that more personal
and the why of that was something that
was really interesting to me
he's very much a character that fixated
on finishing the mission so why not make
the most extreme version of that why not
make that personal uh
and then
beyond that how did he get to be the
buzz that we know how do we get this to
make him into a space ranger that we
recognize and what are the things that
changed him or made him become this hero
[Music]
there's obviously a lot of you have to
show things over time
a lot of versions of things lots of it
just it's a lot of assets it's a lot of
um tracking
what specific idea that you want to be
telling at any given beats on the
montage we we had a version of the
montage that was much longer it was just
too much stuff to track i mean the
audiences can really only follow
a couple of themes through that montage
and you have to communicate that
you know the world is aging without buzz
you also have to communicate that his
best friend is also aging and that
there's a life that's being lived there
that's being missed and you have to
um show through that passage of time the
advancement of a colony so that you can
see that the world moves on as well
another thing that kind of fit hand in
glove with the
the time dilation was i feel like toy
story is such a you know it's a toy
based thing i like toys a lot but i was
always irritated by
the way that
uh toy companies would maximize or
expand the toy lines in unnatural ways
by changing the outfits of characters
that didn't have anything to do with the
story it always kind of wrangled me a
little bit so i was like is there a way
you could tell a story where the hero
would have different outfits that were
story based there were different colors
that was a bit of an interesting
challenge if you have buzz who has an
iconic look to him and we can get that
in the movie in a couple of different
ways how would you show different
outfits that would be
appropriate for the story toys are
selected to be sold and communicate an
idea to kids there's a method to the way
people are attracted to those things i
think there's a similarity to the way
that people can be attracted to uh
stories and points and stories
and it seems like a really weird way to
go about your thinking for it but it
made perfect sense in my mind and it was
kind of thematic to the the origins of
of buzz as a toy
that there would be such clear
design considerations
[Music]
you